かざわー狭い方はせ万円かな広くだねぇ
すぐ方から落ちる9こっちってなって3年は自分じゃつければはこれ1人が難しいって
や無理だわ陸奥ぶりですは結果をもっとう
ストリーできるもんじゃねーよ馬鹿
わー肩幅ばんこにちゃん乗り物の方です新発売のペップ c ゴースト
見捨てに触ればという私ははてた正直何な時間はかな
謎だは謎だ
肩幅しまいミステリーフレーバーって書いてあるから味はからねなぜなら地下で飲み物
の世界からやってきたらどういう音の桜です今日は俺は今日非常に怒っている
今日は非常に怒ってるよ2今日は動画を一本取ったんだよ
個人的にはすごい楽しみですっごぃ欲しかった物ってすごいしたかったとか襲ったんだ
けどもうもうねなんかね
俺のせいじゃない本当に今回に関してはね俺のせいじゃないからね
あの動画を撮ったんですいつも沿ってこのカメラねそうとっだ動画をされ編集しようか
なとってパソコに行ってこう
復活カチカスって言ったらペインターだね動画のデータが破損ファイルになってるん
ですよ
まぁそこまではいいはそこまでは分かるレイター発送することがあるからね sd
カードもねすごいアローンでかすかにもにーではない
了解して8秒介したけどもおかしいなと思っていますかとビデオカメラ esp カード
を刺しましたとしたらあデーターが保存しているように復元しますかみたいな
よかった復元できるんだなと思って入ってをして復元中でしばらくお待ちください線
要素
べきできるって風景完了しましたきましたよしこれで共同編集
いけると思ってパソコンの前にこう言って
肩幅でパソコンでコーヒー楽とかせたで編集しようってん動画の椅子ベビーカーとみる
と sd カードにデータがありません
馬鹿にしてるのが多いうんすごい追い方つ苦言しましたと言ったのに復元されるところ
が道路データが消えてるわけなんですよ
って俺も怒ってるよ俺は今日完全に起こっている
コア
美女カメラん
それは服ゲートいわさくぞという今日こんな訳のわかんね動画塗料ってじゃなかった茶
道具があるんですけどもデータが破損してしまったので今日はその後常について怒っ
誘導型のようなと方です今後よろしくお願いします
最近ね食べ物の棒っていう俺とは別にもう1人方がいるんだけどその方から何か僕
目指しプレイでき
法則方向して母のあるけど好きですけどやって失敗してそれをちょっと購入逆目にとっ
て選んだね
バリーととっ捕まえる防泥それを込んで興亜できますみたいな動画を出してもう俺は
やってみよやってるいいオレがないそういう棒で何かしろやみたいなんだなぁ
音速方向音ズレ両側宝庫するやつ僕たちで気がしたんですよあの笑えない本のやつね
救急病院送りになって
でも穴脳はなの血が止まらなくてもう一歩手術で一打差人口候補につけてしばらく秒に
いなきゃいけないからのレベルの合計がをしたので
その勝利アドラーということをちゃんと言わなきゃいけないなと思いましたまたね他の
機械で何ができればいいとこれは思っているというものの方でした
形ねホテルというよりもええ
泣いてるよ削除すんだよせめてデータ等のかして欲しかった
難しいよ
世の中本当に難しいローさんがプロデューサ美味しいですもう一つとお知らせがあるん
ですけども肇社長というかも
t シャツがですねもうすぐ再販されますアマゾンはなく反映がで遅いだしてこの品が
を何時に出ますっていうことは言えないんですけどもう近い時間批判されるようなので
よかったらそちらの方凡戦教えて下さいながそんな肇社長 t シャツ再販
します知った明日強化した中だと思います
の3モード no でした僕ているというより呆れてんなら弾次回のとは
世界の童話とか言っちゃった次回の動画でお会いしましょう
じゃあ
ん